round three of the Sinquefield cup in  st. Louis the capital of chess in the US  the world's top grandmasters return to  do battle in an event where over half  the game so far have ended in decisive  victory US Champion Wesley soul battle  his compatriot and Chiron out the world  but despite being a pawn down the former  four time national champ was able to  defuse the attack and keep was in a  striking distance of first place one or  two mistakes and he'll probably end up  losing the game but unfortunately he  depended really well co-leader boxing by  Sheila Groff had a golden opportunity to  defeat Peter Spindler but some slick  defense by the seven o'clock Russian  champion cause the position to fizzle  out for seems wrong angler - eh it's my  lord that stinks people in the  tournament is heating up with dynamic  matchups on every board round four  action starts right now  [Music]